[Music]  i think your car is broken sir i  expected more from you matthew  is this who you want to be  they say the summer when you finish  school is the best time of your life  your final summer of freedom  when you become a man it's important  we just didn't realize how important it  would be  [Music]  boys we're free i love you  i think you look great pregnant has  anyone ever told you you have an  extremely comfortable face  i saw a girl get knocked over today  she died but you're fine  [Music]  [Applause]  well that's final big blowout of the  summer  god is in his church  ladies and gentlemen the real man what  was in the bag sugar  what do you think was in the bag with  you you knew what he was like i told you  body of christ  you